[Musique]
bonsoir l'histoire que je m'apprête à
vous comptez aurait pu commencer par il
était une fois parce que rien mais
vraiment rien ne me prédestinait à
prendre des risques
c'était une personne tout à fait
ordinaire qui pratiquer un métier
absolument ordinaire dans une famille
très ordinaire jusqu'à la naissance de
notre second enfant
julie en 1999 julie n'est pas là ce soir
mais je tiens à remercier d'avoir
accepté de partager avec nous quelques
photographies après sa naissance
très rapidement toute une succession de
petites mauvaises nouvelles se sont
enchaînées beaucoup trop nombreuses pour
qu'on puisse parler dans hasard après
des mois d'errance diagnostic de
questionnements c'est moi comme maman
j'ai fini par poser la question à notre
pédiatre est ce qu'on ne devrait pas
poser penser à une maladie génétique
et là bingo après trois mois nous
apprenions que notre fille était
atteinte de tetra zoo me x une maladie
très rare qui ne touchaient qu'une
centaine de femmes dans le monde
nul n'est jamais préparé à affronter une
maladie rare et c'est pourtant ce jour
là qui a débuté une aventure humaine
extraordinaire totalement déroutante
mais aussi très riche en expériences
inattendues extraordinaire parce que la
maladie est hors norme elle ne
correspond à aucun critère d'évaluation
habituel elle n'est sur aucune liste
et elle ne rentre dans aucune case
déroutante parce que vous ne trouvez
absolument rien comme information sur la
maladie
rien ne se passe comme vous l'aviez
prévu comme vous l'aviez imaginé
personne ne vous parle des aides qui
existent qui pourrait faciliter votre
quotidien
pourtant il y en a toute une série mais
personne ne vous en parle
vous avez beaucoup de peine aussi à
trouver des informations sur vos droits
sur ceux de vos enfants vous consacrer
tout votre temps à la maladie toute
votre énergie aussi vous mettez votre
vie professionnelle entre parenthèses où
la plupart du temps vous la voyez même
disparaître surtout si vous êtes une
maman avec des conséquences économiques
potentiellement catastrophique pour
certains il faut savoir que la maladie
rare est un synonyme d'appauvrissement
pour beaucoup de gens sur le plan social
vous voyez votre vie sociale vos loisirs
progressivement disparaître et même
votre famille la plus proche
vos amis peinent à se représenter ce que
vous vivez au quotidien c'est
incompréhensible pour eux ils pensent
bien faire mais il n'arrive pas à saisir
ce que ça représente vraiment vous
retrouvez donc seul trait sol jusqu'à ce
que vous rencontriez d'autres personnes
confrontées à la même situation
c'est cette histoire que nous avons
vécue et que raconte la plupart des
personnes concernées
les représentations que ce fonds le
public les médias le monde politique nos
décideurs notre société des maladies
rares sont la plupart du temps
extrêmement floue mais au fait c'est
quoi une maladie rare en europe
on définit une maladie comme étant rare
lorsqu'elle touche moins d'une personne
sur 2000 alors si elles sont vraiment
aussi rare que ça mais pourquoi en
parler
et bien parce que elle représente à elle
seule près dans cars 2 des 30000 maladie
qu'on connaît donc c'est une raison
suffisante pour en parler à mes yeux
et si les maladies elles sont rares les
patients eux sont vraiment nombreux ces
maladies elles touchent entre 6 et 8% de
la population ça fait globalement à peu
près une personne sur 15 dans cette
salle le nombre de personnes qu'on a
estimé avoir c'est à peu près 180 donc
statistiquement ça veut dire que 10 à 12
personnes parmi nous pourraient être
touchés par une maladie rare
c'est quand même beaucoup hein
j'aimerais faire une comparaison aussi
avec une maladie chronique ordinaire
beaucoup plus connu c'est le diabète
parce que le diabète en fait ils tous à
peu près le même nombre de passions que
les maladies rares la différence c'est
qu'avec le diabète on n'est pas du tout
dans cette constellation là le diabète
on connaît sait comment faire on a des
spécialistes des diabétologues et
endocrinologues on a des médicaments
on sait que ces médicaments ils vont
être remboursés il n'y a pas de problème
majeur avec ça ou presque c'est une
affaire qui roule
excusez moi pour les éventuels
diabétiques qui serait dans la salle je
sais que ça peut très difficile mais
malgré tout comparativement aux maladies
rares
c'est pas tout à fait pareil les
maladies rares c'est une toute autre
histoire
les patients leurs proches se heurte à
l'incompréhension générale
surtout lorsque la maladie ne se voit
pas les compétences des professionnels
sont souvent lacunaires
c'est un petit clin d'oeil pour certains
de mes amis médecins ils n'ont pas eu de
formation dans le domaine des maladies
rares pendant leurs études et du coup ça
pose beaucoup de problèmes parce que
quand ils sont confrontés à des
symptômes incohérent de leurs patients
ils ont tendance à banaliser ou bien
alors à dire que c'est des problèmes psy
qu'il colle le plus souvent sur le dos
de la mer pas très drôle c'est la vérité
c'est très long pour avoir un diagnostic
il faut attendre des mois parfois même
des années si tant est que vous avez la
chance d'en avoir un jour
et quand on a un diagnostic après on se
pose des questions par rapport au
pronostic
mais là aussi point d'interrogation le
la plupart du temps il est inconnu ou
bien alors très pessimiste et la
médecine n'apporte que très rarement les
réponses espérées
le nombre des traitements la recherche
sont insuffisants pour quelle raison
parce qu'en fait les pharmas ils
hésitent à se lancer dans des procédures
très longues très coûteuses ou
potentiellement l'intérêt économique la
rentabilité économique ne serait pas au
rendez vous au final ça veut dire que
plus de 95% des maladies rares ne
bénéficie d'aucun traitement 95%
alors si la maladie qui vous touche ou
qui touchent votre enfant a la chance de
bénéficier d'un traitement vous dit tout
va bien mais la réalité c'est pas tout à
fait ça parce que ça n'est pas parce
qu'il ya un traitement que vous avez la
garantie que ce traitement va être
remboursée par les assurances sociales
pour quelle raison parce que comme ces
maladies sont rares elles ne figurent
pas sur les listes qui servent de sésame
à le remboursement
donc il ya vraiment une forme criante
d'inégalité de traitement pour ces gens
là je vous rappelle accessoirement que
l'assurance maladie est obligatoire que
vous comme moi comme les patients
atteints de maladies rares on paye des
cotisations de primes maladie par contre
vraiment pour le remboursement soit des
tests soient des traitements c'est pas
du tout la même source
j'aimerais aussi parlé des mots qui sont
utilisés par les interlocuteurs auxquels
on est confrontés pour nous parler des
mots d'une violence inouïe qu'on nous
assène soi disant pour communiquer avec
nous mais avec des effets absolument
dévastateur quelques exemples dans ce
nuage de mots débilité mentale profonde
aberrations chromosomiques mongoloïde
handicap et la cerise sur le gâteau
c'est une phrase que nous a écrit une
assurance protection juridique que nous
avions sollicité et qui nous a répondu
la survenue du sinistre est antérieure à
la conclusion du contrat
je traduis la survenue du sinistre
voulait dire la naissance de notre fils
je crois que j'ai pas besoin d'en
rajouter davantage un beau jour j'en ai
eu assez pour notre fille pour défendre
ses droits
je me suis informé je me suis engagé et
je suis parti aux combes au combat
franchement mais ce que j'ai l'air d'une
guerrière c'est vraiment n'importe quoi
mais combat parcours du combattant
ce sont les termes qui utilisent les
gens qui vivent ce genre de situation
j'ai donc assigné en justice à plusieurs
reprises l'assurance sociale qui refusé
injustement de rembourser tout ce qui
concernait notre fille et julie a gagné
quatre fois sur cinq
j'ai donc voulu que les personnes à qui
on annonçait un diagnostic de maladies
rares ne revive pas la même chose que ce
que nous avions vécu en famille j'ai
souhaité que notre expérience nos
batailles serve à d'autres et en 2012
après une conversation avec mon mari qui
a glissé une petite phrase comme ça qui
a servi de déclencheur
je me suis inscrite à une formation une
spécialisation dans le domaine des
maladies rares et de la génétique à
l'étranger parce que rien n'existait
dans ce domaine là en suisse
à ce moment là j'ai abandonné ma
profession et j'ai monté en valais un
projet novateur qui n'existait nulle
part en suisse
un projet destiné à améliorer la qualité
de vie
le parcours de vie et de santé des
personnes concernées un parcours axé sur
la formation l'accompagnement et la
coordination des interventions
j'aime beaucoup cette phrase de senécal
mais honnêtement je dois dire que je ne
suis pas sûr que j'aurais osé si j'avais
su à quel point la route serait longue
j'ai lu un jour qu'entre le moment où on
débute un projet est celui où il est
pérennisée et ça coule en moyenne 17 ans
alors j'ai fait le calcul s'était vite
faire dans 17 ans nasri à la retraite
donc ce n'est pas moi qui vais voir ça
alors maintenant le succès il commence à
être au rendez vous c'est formidable
mais rien n'a été simple
j'ai eu des périodes de doute absolument
immense un mille fois j'ai pensé
abandonner
j'ai rencontré des obstacles sur ma
route auquel je m'attendais absolument
pas et je dois dire que j'ai travaillé
que je travaille toujours en permanence
hors de ma zone de confort
mon père qui est décédé en 2016 m'a dit
alors que je lui ai expliqué en quoi
consistait mes activités
ma fille tu as choisi une voie bien
rocailleuse notre fils lui s'est écrié
mais ma môme est à inventer un nouveau
métier c'était un peu interloquée mais
en fait avec le recul je réalise qu'il
avait tout à fait raison
quant aux bénévoles de la fondation
active dans le domaine dans le transfert
de compétences qui m'a aidé à monter ce
projet quand on est arrivé au bout de
notre collaboration il a conclu en
citant mark twain
il ne savait pas que c'était impossible
alors ils l'ont fait ce projet a
débouché l'année dernière sur la
création de l'association maraval
maladies rares valley qui est la
première structure cantonale
intégralement dédié aux maladies rares
dans notre pays nous poursuivons les
activités qui avaient été menées
précédemment il nous fédérons à la fois
les patients leurs proches et aussi les
professionnels qui s'occupent de ces
gens là avec notre association nous
estimons qu'il est de la responsabilité
de notre société d'assumer ces
personnes-là d'assumer ses
responsabilités à la fois morale sociale
et financière
face aux plus vulnérables c'est-à-dire
ceux pour qui le fardeau de la maladie
rare et le plus lourd le plus difficile
donc nous allons continuer nous avons
osé nous allons tout prochainement
débuter des négociations avec l'état du
valais pour aller dans ce sens là et
nous allons continuer à prendre des
risques parce que les patients atteints
de maladies rares sont des citoyens
comme les autres ce ne sont pas des
citoyens de seconde zone et ils ont le
droit d'être traités de façon équitable
j'espère vous en avoir convaincu ce soir
le risque à ce stade n'est plus une
option c'est juste une évidence
avant de nous quitter je vous invite à
visionner ensemble une vidéo qui a été
fait par eurordis l'alliance européenne
des maladies rares à l'occasion de la
journée européenne des malades pardon
internationale des maladies rares qui a
eu lieu cette semaine et je vous
remercie de votre attention
[Applaudissements]
dans une tuerie
trente deux chercheurs where you less
d'affilée
belmont
ce time to her get well soon
shay ouvert leurs portes closes
comment pour wii
kemboi champion lleyton hewitt
shiga merci de ton talent